there's also going to be controversy and
I just have to ask you your thoughts on
somebody who's supposedly rumored has a
high net worth and we don't really know
what someone's net worth or what their
obligations are financially how do you
feel about them utilizing platforms that
were generally for the unknown artists
well I mean and then you're probably
alluding to the controversy that takes
place whenever like some mega movie star
goes out and does a crowdfunding
campaign and I'm of the school that says
this is this is great you know that the
the ebb and flow of of creating projects
and being in between projects and coming
up with new ideas is the same for
somebody that's uber famous as it is for
somebody who might not be famous it's
all scalable but what it what it does do
when you come up with a crowdfunding
campaign and you know like if I asked my
mom she probably now knows what
Kickstarter is and she didn't know what
that was before and that's what it does
I mean we're shifting the paradigm from
saying i have this goal in life there's
things out there that can help me
achieve that goal and so you know why
does anybody have a spokesperson for any
sort of company or any sort of industry
it's because you want to get word out
about that industry so whenever somebody
famous has a successful crowdfunding
campaign it just sheds a lot of light on
crowdfunding and and I look at that as a
plus and not so much minus I don't think
it just attracts from my ability to do
crowdfunding campaign if anything it
increases the pool of people that may
find out about my project it might not
otherwise have known about it and that's
helpful so what do you think the
animosity comes from because if you go
to any of these high-level campaigns
you'll see all these different comments
and it'd be just easy to label them as
haters and some I'm sure are but then
there's some that legitimately feel that
these individuals should not be able to
crowd fun what do you think that stems
from I don't know you know I run a blog
filmmaking stuff and I got to tell you
every once in a while that I'll never
forget I don't know why it still bothers
me but one time I sent this email out
about this blog posts that are
yeah it was just like it took me some
time to write it I was like really
excited about I was like this is going
to help somebody like I legitimately had
those thoughts like this is the thing I
wish I knew ten years ago and now I
wrote it and I email it out and one of
my first responses was this guy Eddie
bro you suck that was it that was it
that's all he wrote two words you suck i
wrote what like 700 words of like this
good like what i thought was really cool
stuff and he's like you suck and I used
to take that stuff personally or if
somebody were to unsubscribe for my
email list and write like a really nasty
comment like oh you know whatever mean
thing they could say I used to read
those things and take him personally
because it may hurt I don't really look
at it that way anymore I'm like I don't
think it's my problem these just weren't
the right fit for me so going back to
your question about you know the haters
or the trolls or the people that are
upset about somebody else having a
successful crowdfunding campaign you
know they're entitled to their opinion I
just I would caution anybody that feels
that negativity to say like while you're
sitting there being negative you're not
really doing any work to improve your
own ability to engage in audience um i
don't i don't know if it's proactive to
sit around and say like oh that person
is more successful than I anyway that's
a great point yeah you know help please
help everybody that's negative i don't i
don't know how to respond to that
because i just dive now grown immune to
it personally so whenever i see like one
of these famous people have a successful
crowdfunding campaign I like feel
encouraged and invigorated because I'm
like here's somebody else proving that
this can be done you know and here's a
cool model to follow maybe I don't have
10,000 people maybe I have 1,000 people
that are going to support my campaign
but I'll do it so much better because
now I I've looked at these role models
and I know how to engage an audience
better and that's it's good stuff so
you